Earth's Yeagers might be headed for
another truly epic showdown with the
Kaiju but you'll likely never get to see
it why does this franchise seem to be
dead in the water
when Pacific Rim was due for release in
2013 Hollywood had high hopes that it
could be the next great franchise after
all the film had all the ingredients of
a smashing success a hot director in
Guillermo del Toro a superstar leading
man in Idris Elba and an impressive cast
of emerging Talent the movie also
matches together two wildly popular
genres giant Kaiju Monsters and
super-sized sci-fi robots but Pacific
Rim underwhelmed at the box office only
barely doubling its budget the sequel
took a while to get up and running as a
result as Warner Brothers stepped away
from the franchise and Universal
Pictures took over nearly five years
after the first movie Pacific Rim
Uprising arrived helmed by Stephen s
denite whether because of the long wait
because it lacked most of the previous
film stars or because it just isn't very
good Uprising was a dud at the box
office and disappointed fans and critics
alike okay we're going with giant robots
again all right real original guys
not pressed
I am dressed moviegoers hoping for a
sequel to round out a Trilogy have their
fingers crossed that they'll still
somehow get their wish but it seems that
the box office results of the original
films just haven't been enough to
convince Hollywood to Green Light
another
ever since Pacific Rim Uprising failed
to set the box office Ablaze the people
behind it have gone looking for answers
about what went wrong for starters
director Stephen s denight talked to
collider about how the movie underwent a
significant overhaul after some poor
test screenings he said when we tested
the movie one of the biggest comments we
got was I don't know where I am in the
world I liked the first movie but I saw
it five years ago I don't really
remember it this might suggest that the
long wait between movies played a part
in losing the audience but returning
actor Charlie Day thinks there are other
reasons Uprising didn't catch on asked
by The Hollywood Reporter in 2022 if the
change in directors was to blame for the
film's failure they had this to say yes
Guillermo del Toro is such a singular
vision and talent someone else can do
someone else but no one can do him he's
a true auteur and when you give an otor
a big franchise thing they're going to
do something really interesting with it
which I think he did
who is that guy everything he comes up
to me and says something or other who is
it well not exactly casting blame on
tonight this does add context to the
poor reviews of Uprising which is often
noted for its lack of originality and
Flair compared to the original
ahead of the release of Pacific Rim
Uprising some were already looking ahead
to a potential Pacific Rim 3. director
Stephen s denight was one of them during
a press junket he told den of geek
hopefully we'll get a chance to do a
third one if the audience shows up for
this one and hopefully I'll be involved
following the film's release though
doubts began to arise about the
prospects of a Pacific Rim 3-qual
eventually the Knight was cornered by
Cinema Blend who asked Point Blank if
Pacific Rim 3 was ever going to happen
he said that is so far above my pay
grade I have heard nothing that is up to
the executives and the bean counters
regardless of how the studio may feel
the director wants it to happen he added
I think the franchise deserves to be
finished whether or not it made enough
money I honestly have no idea long ago I
kind of disconnected myself to any kind
of box office worry things like that are
kind of out of my hand but I certainly
hope so I have heard nothing but I hope
there's another installment
today we are canceling the Apocalypse
while Idris Elba and Charlie Hunnam
didn't return for Pacific Rim Uprising
at least one of them could make a
comeback if a third film happens
Stephen estenite once told Phantom that
he loves Charlie Hunnam explaining that
a scheduling conflict with another
project took him away from the first
sequel the Knight also made it clear
that there is room for him to return if
the third film ever materializes he
explained we've left it open I have a
great idea for how to fold him back into
the next installment if he's available
and If the schedules work this statement
also suggests that another of the
franchise's stars is likely to feature
in a third installment too if the Knight
has anything to say about it that is
interviews with Star John boyega suggest
he'd be more than happy to reprise his
role as Jake petticos too though his
more recent comments regarding the Star
Wars sequel Trilogy could suggest he
probably isn't eager to take part in
another franchise
thank you
Pacific Rim Uprising may not deliver a
story quite like the first films but it
does fill out the world expand on the
lore and set up the franchise for a
third entry that could completely change
the stakes notably Uprising reveals new
information on the alien race called the
precursors the true villains of Pacific
Rim who were intent on Conquering the
planet by sending the Kaiju to wreak
havoc on Earth in Pacific Rim Uprising
we learned that the precursors have an
ally on Earth who has been serving as an
Inside Man by orchestrating Kaiju
invasions when that person is found out
and confronted we get a clear idea of
where a Pacific Rim 3 could go we're
gonna keep
it's going to run out meanwhile in a
post-credits scene Jake Pentecost says
they'll need a new battle plan if
they're going to defeat the Monstrous
Menace once and for all this means
taking the fight to the kaijus realm
which is exactly what boyega told IGN
during a chat about Pacific Rim 3. he
said we'll probably have to go to their
world this time we're going to need
something different I mean Yeagers won't
be able to go through there the way we
want them to but maybe we'll try and
build something else
though we may have a decent idea of
which cast members could return to
continue the Pacific Rim series there's
another question to consider who would
direct a third installment while Stephen
estenite has spoken often about his
hopes for a third film some of his
comments cast doubt on the idea of him
returning in 2018 he spoke with Cinema
Blend and was asked if there would be
another movie his response implied it
could happen but without him at the helm
he said I hope with or without me
because my schedule is starting to get a
little complicated that there's a third
installment because I would love to see
it this suggests he may not return even
if there is another film if he doesn't
come back the potential then arises for
series Creator Guillermo del Toro to
return to the director's chair
unfortunately he doesn't seem all that
Keen on coming back himself in 2021 Del
Toro chatted with fans of Pacific Rim on
Twitter and said that while he would
love to see another film it'll be as a
fan he said no plans to return so where
does that leave us well some have
suggested Vincenzo Natali could be a
possibility to direct Pacific Rim 3. the
Cube director has collaborated with Del
Toro before having directed several
episodes of Guillermo del Toro's Cabinet
of Curiosities and the strain if Pacific
Rim 3 ever comes together what will it
be about well we know where Pacific Rim
Uprising sets it up to go and we know
where Star John boyega wants to take it
tell them next time they won't need to
worry about coming for us
because we're gonna come for them
a sequel is primed to take Jaegers and
their human Pilots through the breach
and into the enemy's domain where they
would fight on an entirely new
battlefield but Guillermo del Toro had
plans for a very different Pacific Rim
sequel at one point and there's always
the possibility that his ideas could be
repurposed for a third film in a 2021
interview with the rap Del Toro talked
about his discarded story and the
secrets it would have revealed about the
wider Pacific Rim Universe he said the
villain was this Tech guy that had
invented basically sort of the internet
2.0 and then they realized that all his
patents came to him one morning and so
little by little they started putting
together this and they said oh he got
them from the precursors the guys that
control the Kaiju Beyond a revelation of
how this technology came to be del
Toro's idea would throw a major twist
into the mix he continued then we found
out that the precursors are us thousands
of years in the future they're trying to
terraform trying to re-harvest the Earth
to survive and that we were in EXO
biosuits that looked alien but they were
not we were inside and it was a really
interesting paradox
way back when the filmmakers behind
Pacific Rim had bigger aspirations than
just a series of movies talking to
Nerdist in 2017 sequel director Stephen
s denied said that in addition to
discussion of a third film conversations
were also taking place regarding ways to
turn the franchise into a full-fledged
Cinematic Universe while Uprising was
still in production the Knight told
Nerdist the plan was always to use this
movie as a launching pad if enough
people show up to this we've already
talked about the plot of the third movie
and how the end of the third movie would
expand the universe to a Star Wars Star
Trek style franchise where you can go in
many many different directions the night
went on to talk about the various ideas
that lay on the drawing board he added
you can go main Canon you can go
spin-offs you can go one-offs yeah
that's the plan and I would love to see
an animated TV show based on this had
Uprising been a hit we could have found
ourselves swimming in Pacific Rim
projects sadly it just wasn't to be
the Pacific Rim Cinematic Universe was
scrapped before it even began audiences
never got Pacific Rim 3 let alone any
spin-offs or other projects but that
doesn't mean that fans have gone
entirely without any new stories in this
world for example the Animated Series
tonight alluded to did make its way to
the small screen
what is this place
Pacific Rim the black debuted as a
Netflix original anime in 2021 produced
jointly by legendary television and
Japanese animation studio polygon
pictures mostly ignoring Pacific Rim
Uprising this series follows up on the
first movie it introduces Taylor and
Haley Travis a brother and sister who
discover an abandoned Jaeger and use it
to battle Kaiju and further their
mission to find their lost parents at
the same time legendary Comics is
published Pacific Rim Comics including
Pacific Rim Amara and Pacific Rim
aftermath these stories build upon the
events of the first movie while Pacific
Rim blackout continues The Adventures of
the anime series
during a press junket for Pacific Rim
Uprising Steven S tonight spoke candidly
about his hopes for the future while the
film's failure at the box office made
another movie hard to get off the ground
there may still be a route to Pacific
Rim 3 if all the stars can align and the
key may be streaming with more streaming
services available than ever before
platforms ranging from Netflix to Amazon
Prime are looking for ways to set
themselves apart
of course that often means investing in
franchises and while Pacific Rim may not
have drawn enough fans to the theater a
third movie could bring in a sizable
streaming audience we've already seen a
Pacific Rim anime series find success on
Netflix and it's not too much of a jump
to imagine they might also invest in a
cinematic sequel or even a live-action
series similarly a nascent streaming
service looking to compete with the
industry's Giants could see Pacific Rim
as a ticket to gaining market share if
there's any hope left of continuing the
franchise now might be the time to
strike